mon nom est entendu ménage explorant l'
herbe robotique est un robot conçu
pour entrer dans les maisons des gens et les aider
dans les tâches quotidiennes afin que vous puissiez imaginer l'
herbe conduire dans une cuisine et aider les
gens à nettoyer la table après un repas
ou aider les gens à préparer un repas ou
transporter leur linge dans la
buanderie, c'est donc vraiment un robot qui
est destiné à aider les personnes, par exemple les
personnes âgées ou
handicapées, à être plus indépendantes chez
elles, donc l'herbe est l'un de nos robots
et nous avons d'autres robots  qui travaillent
au lieu d'être autonomes qui
travaillent avec d'autres personnes afin d'effectuer les
mêmes types de tâches pour aider les personnes
handicapées à vivre de manière plus autonome
pour pouvoir vivre une vie plus riche et plus complète
sans avoir besoin de dépendre d'autres
personnes